sexualize and videotape when you know
that movie came out James Spader when
that movie came out I remember they
wanted to show
um him pleasuring himself but in a way
that was acceptable in the late 80s so
he'd have no shirt on
and he'd just be
rubbing his fingers across the top of
his chest and uh I remembered that took
me completely out of the movie like oh
okay
that doesn't seem that efficient that's
I'm sorry
I don't think that's going to get the
job done it depends on how long you got
I mean
you know what's funny about that is that
now cut to
um I don't know what the rating is on my
show you but yeah I was gonna say I'm
I'm now famous for among other things
masturbating right well the thing is I'm
on your show
it's even in the pilot they have it they
have it happening in the in you know so
the pilots in the pilots you are
watching the object of your affection
from across the street and um you start
uh taking care of business and you're
not what we call Spader baiting
you are uh
you are really doing it and and then I'm
wondering what what is there Direction
involved what does the director say so
this is this is this is uh this has been
a recurring thing on the show it has I
actually spoke about this and you know
they love to see it as they say I um
from what so first of all what's
interesting about this is it is on 19th
Street and Gramercy which is the first
Street I lived on in New York city so it
was it was the added bit of surreality
for me is that I it was it very much was
like a neighborhood street for me like I
was very much at home but now surrounded
by a film crew at like you know 11 pm at
night and um
and by the way like keep in mind not
looking at anything real I'm looking at
an x a tape marker right they're holding
like uh it's it they're holding like a
there's like a fishing pole with a golf
ball hanging off of it and they're
saying just look at that and pretend
that it's right an erotic woman and um
and I and I meant to be pleasuring
myself and
um
you don't realize how awkward it's gonna
be until you just gotta go ahead and act
like that and
um and one of the things that I
struggled with a lot when I first took
the role was like I don't want to lean
away from the horrific aspects of this
person I I you know I don't want to be
just as we've said you know it's hard
not to glorify actually almost anything
you see on camera so I'm gonna just be
conscious of that and so I
I was doing it and I and and I think so
there were two things that that that uh
that I did that were
um and again I don't know what happened
I don't remember what they used I don't
remember I don't so I it may not be this
way in the in the show but what I did up
until the director came and was like you
can't do that anymore is that I was slow
and my eyes were open
[Laughter]
I was like I
am
and I am not gonna
and I like that a director came over and
said you've got to stop that now
and uh
you know and uh-huh and and at some
point
um and his his name is Lee tolin Krieger
shout out to Lee I've now you know
shouting him out a few times so you're
welcome Lee hi Lee uh yeah he he comes
up and he's he was trying to be very
kind and he was like Hey so um
I think I think we're gonna have to get
you to close your eyes
you know
well now I know why I didn't get his
role
and and I and I remember I was because I
was already very conscious of not
wanting to be like sexily masturbating
outside of the street by the way if I
name it it's weird but it's the show
kills her at the end spoiler alerts you
can put a spoiler alert before that
there you go
sorry it's weird because I have to but
it's like you know this is this is this
is it's not it's no secret yep and you
know it's like
it's very intense to play this person
and you know and I was kind of I was
already like why why why why
why like why tell me why do I why are my
eyes closed yeah you know just just
being very principled and this is where
you know at this point I don't know what
I was thinking as an actor but just as a
person who was uncomfortable I just I
just was kind of ready to go by the way
my version of confrontational the people
pleaser that I am working all my life
and in Hollywood was like okay okay
in my mind I'm like why why why why why
why
and I was probably just like okay you
know what I wish I don't remember what I
actually I wish Frank McCord had been
there oh if you don't want to [ __ ]
jerk off I thought that someone else
would be willing to do it for a couple
hundred [ __ ] thousand dollars
I'm not comfortable with this ah you
don't want to whack it to you well let
me tell you something
that sorry that started the three into
like a wrap almost
um yeah yeah and so and so and I don't
remember anybody telling me to speed up
but I think I just did because it felt
so weird to be going so slow yeah yeah
and then they use what they use whatever
you can go back and watch whatever it is
I don't remember what what it is I don't
remember what it is I think the director
just put it on Fast Forward he sped up
the film so you were doing it really
slow but it's like
and in the background cars are going
really fast and the sun comes up and
goes down like three times